This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. We're based in beautiful downtown Oakland, California, which is a port city on the San Francisco Bay. Massive container ships travel across the Pacific and end up here. From miles away, you can see the enormous white cranes that pull giant, uniformly sized metal boxes off the ships. People say the cranes are the inspiration for the adat walkers and the Empire Strikes Back, but that's not true. It's just a good story to tell
这里是“百分之九十九的隐形”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。我们的总部位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的市中心，这是一座位于旧金山湾的港口城市。巨大的集装箱货轮横跨太平洋，最终抵达这里。在几英里外，你就能看到巨大的白色起重机，它们把巨大且尺寸统一的金属箱从船上吊卸下来。人们说这些起重机是《帝国反击战》中全地形装甲步行机的灵感来源，但事实并非如此。这只是一个适合在经过桥梁时讲给别人听的好故事。
when you pass by on the bridge. The port of Oakland and its container ships have always captured my imagination, and it turns out they also captured the imagination of my colleague and friend Alexis Madrigal. I went out, I visited a ship that was docked in Oakland, and when I went out on the ship, I walked into this room that was all wood-paneled
当你路过大桥时。奥克兰港及其集装箱货轮一直吸引着我的想象力，事实证明，它们也吸引了我的同事兼朋友阿历克斯·马德里加尔的想象力。我走出去，参观了一艘停泊在奥克兰的船，当我走到船上时，我走进了一个全木质镶板的房间。
and this kind of old Romanian captain walks in with his marble reds and he sits him down on the table and he looks right in my eyes and he goes, what is your intent? And I was just gladotters in love, like from this love it first sight. I was just like, no one ever hears these voices. They're so amazing. So there's kind of two head people on a ship.
然后一个有点像老罗马尼亚船长的家伙走了进来，手里拿着他的大理石红塔山香烟，他在桌子旁坐下，直视着我的眼睛说：“你们的意图是什么？”我当时简直爱惨了，就像一见钟情那样。我当时就想，从来没有人听到过这些声音。它们太神奇了。所以一艘船上通常有两个负责人。
One is the captain, the other is the chief engineer down in the engine room. And so we, you know, we looked at bridge and we went back to that wood paneled room. And the chief engineer comes in another Romanian dude and he goes You visited the head of the ship and he taps his chest Now visit the heart He takes us down into the engine room You know with these just like wrenches that are like you know five feet tall And I honestly I really could not imagine not doing a series of stories after that
一个是船长，另一个是机舱里的大管轮。所以我们，你知道的，我们看了看驾驶台，然后回到了那个木质镶板的房间。大管轮进来了，又是一个罗马尼亚老兄，他说：“你们拜访了船头。”他拍了拍自己的胸口，“现在去拜访心脏吧。”他把我们带到了机舱里。你知道的，那里有那种差不多五英尺高的扳手。老实说，我真的无法想象在那之后不做出一系列的故事。
And I went home and I had some wine and I was like drunk tweeting about how amazing would it be to just tell the stories of all these people in the supply chain and that's what happened. Alexis decided to embark on an eight part series called Containers about how the shipping container has changed the global economy. We're gonna feature one of the stories from that series on the show today,
我回家喝了点酒，然后在推特上借着酒劲发推说，如果能把供应链中所有这些人的故事都讲出来，那该有多棒啊，事情就是这样。阿历克斯决定着手制作一个名为《集装箱》的八集系列节目，讲述航运集装箱是如何改变全球经济的。今天我们将在节目中播放该系列中的一个故事，
but first I wanted to talk a little with Alexis about what the world was like before the container. So like before the 1970s or so, starting with the ports. So if you want to think about what a port was like in the old days, just look at the piers, look at how they're shaped. They're these long kind of fingers coming off of the shoreline. Well, the ships would have pulled up into what those are called finger piers. And then they would have unloaded their stuff. There would have been all these hundreds of people running around and ships would have pulled up into what those are called finger piers. And then they would have unloaded their stuff.
但在那之前，我想和阿历克斯稍微聊聊集装箱出现之前的世界是什么样的。比如大约20世纪70年代之前，我们先从港口说起。如果你想了解过去港口是什么样的，看看那些码头就知道了，看看它们的形状。它们是从海岸线延伸出来的长条状突堤。嗯，船只过去会停靠在这些被称为手指状码头的地方。然后它们会在那里卸货。会有成百上千的人四处奔跑，船只过去会停靠在那些被称为手指状码头的地方。然后它们会在那里卸货。
There would have been all these hundreds of people running around and they would have unloaded their stuff directly onto those piers, which would have then gone into cargo sheds. So you've got guys working winchets, you know, kind of like little mini cranes on the boats. And you've got all the stuff sort of stored inside the hull of the ship. That was the container. They're dropping it onto the docks. Other people are forklifting it around. Trucks are pulling up. There's all these crews running everywhere.
会有成百上千的人四处奔跑，他们会把货物直接卸到那些码头上，然后货物会进入仓库。所以你会看到有人在操作绞车，你知道的，就像船上的那种小型迷你起重机。所有的东西都储存在船体内部。这就是集装箱。他们把货物扔到码头上。其他人用叉车搬运。卡车开过来。到处都是跑来跑去的工人们。
And so the notion of the docks, like the waterfront, this sort of charismatic place that I think lots of people know and understand, it's because there were all these people from all over the world and the goods themselves, literally the stuff coming from all these places is visible to your view. So you can smell the coffee when the spice ships come in. You'd smell the cardamom. When there was something that was disgusting, like hides that was being worked, you'd smell green hides being handled by people. You would have seen big rolls of newsprint moving around, right? Like the way the world worked was actually sort of exposed to you before it got re-put in to factories and products
因此，码头的概念，比如滨水区这样一个充满魅力的地方，我想很多人都知道并理解，是因为这里有来自世界各地的人们，货物本身，也就是从这些地方运来的东西，完全呈现在你的视野中。所以当香料船进港时，你能闻到咖啡的香味。你会闻到小豆蔻的味道。当有令人作呕的东西时，比如正在加工的兽皮，你会闻到人们在处理生兽皮的气味。你会看到一大卷新闻纸在移动，对吧？世界的运作方式其实是直接展现在你面前的，在它们被重新投入工厂和产品
and all these things. And so it was actually this incredible site, you know, I had an old longshoreman, you know, graduated high school, but only high school. And he said, you know, there was an entire education about the way the world worked, just looking at the goods that were sitting on the docks. When people started shipping things in containers, goods could be loaded and offloaded more easily. The containers full of stuff could go directly from the ship onto trucks and trains, and everything was standardized all over the world.
以及所有这些东西之前。所以这实际上是一个不可思议的场景，你知道，我遇到过一个老码头工人，你知道的，高中毕业，但也只是高中毕业。他说，你知道的，关于世界是如何运作的，有一整课的教育，仅仅通过看着码头上的货物就能学到。当人们开始用集装箱运输货物时，货物的装卸变得更加容易。装满货物的集装箱可以直接从船上转运到卡车和火车上，全世界的一切都实现了标准化。
Containers eliminated a lot of inefficiencies from the system, and ports have completely changed. You know, ports now are these long, flat bursts. The ships come in, they dock, and then, you know, these largely white container cranes drop over them. Those cranes are really a wild thing when you think about it. The reason they're next are so long that's called the boom is because the ships are so wide. They go out over the whole ship, and then a little person in a little cab goes out all the way across the ship, and they look down through their legs, they drop this thing called a spreader onto these four locking mechanisms on the box. They pull it up, they bring it, they drop it onto an intermediate truck that takes it into
集装箱消除了系统中的许多低效环节，港口也发生了翻天覆地的变化。你知道的，现在的港口都是长而平坦的泊位。船只进港，停泊，然后，你知道的，这些主要是白色的集装箱起重机就会笼罩在它们上方。仔细想想，那些起重机真的是一种疯狂的东西。它们悬臂那么长的原因，被称为起重臂，是因为船太宽了。它们伸展到整艘船的上方，然后一个小驾驶室里的小人横跨整艘船，他们从双腿之间往下看，把一个叫做吊具的东西降落到箱子上的四个锁紧机构上。他们把它拉起来，拿过来，把它降落到一辆中转卡车上，由卡车把它运到
the holding yard. Then a Dreyage truck comes in, drives through West Oakland, spraying diesel all over the community, and then takes it out to a distribution center in Tracy or wherever it is. That's a pretty normal flow. But containers didn't just have an effect on ports. They had an effect on port cities all over the world. Oakland included. Because absolutely everything about the way that cities work and global trade works was
堆场。接着一辆集卡开进来，穿过西奥克兰，向整个社区喷洒柴油，然后把它运到特雷西或其他什么地方的分销中心。这是一个相当正常的流程。但集装箱不仅对港口产生了影响，它们还对世界各地的港口城市产生了影响。奥克兰也不例外。因为城市运作的方式和全球贸易运作的方式绝对方方面面都被
changed by the system of containerization, not just the box, but everything that went along with it, the locking mechanisms, the operations of the yard, the ships that had to be developed in order to carry more containers. And basically, one way that I've thought about it is there were computers before and there was networking before, but then there was this thing called Internet Protocol that allowed like a packet to be moved around no matter what was inside them, and that allows
集装箱化系统所改变，不仅仅是这个箱子，还有与之配套的一切，锁紧机构、堆场的运营、为了运载更多集装箱而必须开发的船舶。基本上，我的一种思考方式是，以前有计算机，以前有网络，然后出现了一种叫做互联网协议的东西，它允许数据包无论里面是什么内容都能被四处传输，这就促成了
for this explosion of networking. That's essentially what containers do for stuff. You can just put any X thing into a box, and it can go to any port. And as I was reading this defining work on this process of containerization called the box, by Gennie Mark Levinson, who's in the series, there's this huge role for Oakland.
网络的大爆发。这基本上就是集装箱对货物所做的事情。你可以把任何东西放进一个箱子里，它就能去往任何港口。正当我阅读这本关于集装箱化进程的开创性著作——由吉尼·马克·莱文森撰写的《箱子》（他也参与了这个系列）时，我发现奥克兰在其中扮演了巨大的角色。
For most intents and purposes, C-LAND is the first major container shipping company. They really get their explosive growth because of the Vietnam War, shipping things from Oakland to Vietnam. And that was so fascinating to me, particularly because almost immediately they go to Vietnam to a container port built in Camron Bay, and then they start going back by Japan. And as they go back by Japan, they pick up cheap electronics and then come back to California and start selling them.
出于各种意图和目的，海陆公司（Sea-Land）是第一家主要的集装箱航运公司。他们确实因为越南战争而获得了爆炸式的增长，将物资从奥克兰运往越南。这让我非常着迷，尤其是因为他们几乎立刻就去了越南金兰湾建造的集装箱港口，然后开始经由日本返回。当他们经由日本返回时，他们会带上廉价的电子产品，然后回到加利福尼亚开始出售它们。
And that becomes this dominant mode of trade in the world. And it literally reshapes the world economy. And it's coming from these three, you know, cranes that are sitting over there, still sitting there unused in the port of Oakland. And I just thought, like, how is this not a better known story after you got started after talking to your Romanian captain and drunk tweeting What were you most surprised by when you started doing the story? I think there's really two things one is the incredible fact that containerization had on cities and that continues to have on cities. The first wave of containerization wipes out so many jobs in urban America and urban coastal America.
这成为了世界上占主导地位的贸易模式。它真正重塑了世界经济。而这一切都源自那三台起重机，你知道的，它们就坐在那边，至今仍未在奥克兰港闲置着。我只是觉得，在你和你的罗马尼亚船长交谈并酒后发推之后，怎么会没有人更了解这个故事呢？当你开始做这个故事时，什么最让你感到惊讶？我认为实际上有两件事，一是集装箱化对城市产生的不可思议的影响，并且这种影响仍在继续。第一波集装箱化摧毁了美国城市和美国沿海城市的大量工作岗位。
It really, really does bad things for a lot of cities. Like, you know, that empty warehouse, Brooklyn aesthetic, like that was those warehouses used to be full with goods. And then containerization came along and wiped out all the warehouses. And that's what created the ability to have these kinds of creative workspaces that you have now. That's your, you're in the energy and the carcass of the old system of trade when you're in one of those spaces. So that was what I didn't, I just had no idea that this happened all over the world and London in New York and San Francisco everywhere.
它确实对许多城市造成了非常非常不好的影响。就像，你知道的，那个空置的仓库，布鲁克林的审美，那些仓库以前装满了货物。然后集装箱化出现了，消除了所有的仓库。而正是这一点创造了拥有你现在拥有的这种创意工作空间的能力。当你身处其中一个空间时，你正处于旧贸易系统能量和躯壳之中。所以我不知道的是，我只是不知道这一切发生在世界各地，伦敦、纽约、圣弗朗西斯科以及所有地方。
Even though the invention of the container wiped out shipping jobs all over the world, there are still a lot of people working in the industry. What those people do, and whether they will be able to hold onto their jobs as the shipping industry continues to change, is what Alexis explores in episode three of containers. You have all these people out there whose jobs are linked in one way or another to things made around the world, and most of them tend to be in places like California, or Virginia, or New York, these big coastal ports. And their jobs and what those jobs are,
尽管集装箱的发明消除了世界各地的海运工作岗位，但仍有许多人在这个行业工作。这些人做什么，以及随着航运业继续发生变化，他们是否能够保住工作，正是阿历克斯在《集装箱》第三集中所探讨的内容。外面有这么多人，他们的工作以这样或那样的方式与世界各地制造的东西联系在一起，他们大多数倾向于生活在加利福尼亚、弗吉尼亚或纽约这样的大型沿海港口。他们的工作以及这些工作到底是什么，
I mean, I had no idea, like what is it to work in a warehouse? What is it to work on a tugboat? What is it to work in a port? There are no stories about these things ever. And so that take away for me is maybe a collage of all these different work experiences and trying to get the texture of those lives and how those people see the world.
我是说，我完全不知道，在仓库工作是什么样的？在拖船上工作是什么样的？在港口工作是什么样的？从来没有关于这些事情的故事。所以我从中得到的收获或许是所有这些不同工作经历的拼图，并试图捕捉这些生活的质感以及这些人是如何看待世界的。
It's kind of like the point of containers. This is episode three of containers called the ships, the tugs, and the port. Here's Alexis Madrigal. He meet a lot of tough people near the docks, intense captains, burly long shorm, and salty skippers, rugged old timers. But I want you to meet the most hardcore person
这有点像集装箱的意义所在。这是《集装箱》的第三集，名为《轮船、拖船与港口》。这位是阿历克斯·马德里加尔。他在码头附近遇到了许多强硬的人，严厉的船长、魁梧的码头工人和粗犷的老船长，坚韧的老手。但我希望你见识一下最硬核的人，
I've met during my time reporting on the waterfront. And I thought to myself, well, I'll go in this career in this industry and kind of see what happens. You know, I'm not thinking that this is my dream to grow up and be a ship's captain. This is Lynn Courwatch. She became the first female captain of an American cargo ship under remarkable circumstances. And during those first years, I had the opportunity to sail initially as a maid on an oil tanker and was in Southern California when a tanker
那是我在滨水区进行报道期间遇到的。我心里想，好吧，我要进入这个职业和这个行业，看看会发生什么。你知道的，我并没有想过长大后成为一名船长是我的梦想。这位是林·库尔沃奇。在奇特的情况下，她成为了美国货船的第一位女船长。在头几年里，我有机会最初作为一名大副在油轮上航行，当时在南加州，一艘油轮
blew up and said, oh man, maybe this is really not the gig that I want. So she joined the master mates in pilot union and began sailing on all kinds of ships around the world. I quickly kind of decided that, you know, going to places like the Far East and South America was a little bit more of a challenge, you know. In the 1970s and early 80s, they had never seen women on ships. Every time she entered a porch, she had to explain to skeptical dockworkers that she wasn't the captain's wife and that the men had to listen to her.
发生了爆炸，我说，天哪，也许这真的不是我想要的工作。于是她加入了船长、大副和领航员工会，开始在世界各地的各种船只上航行。我很快就决定，你知道的，去远东和南美洲等地是一个更大的挑战，你知道的。在20世纪70年代和80年代初，他们从未在船上见过女性。每次她进入港口，她都必须向怀疑的码头工人解释她不是船长的妻子，而且男人们必须听从她的指挥。
It was tough work. So she decided to try to work her way up at the American shipping line, Matsum, which ran and still runs, shipped from Oakland, a Hawaiian back. I had the opportunity over the years to advance to the chief mates position at Matsum. They were very good to me. And when an opportunity came up to be promoted on a temporary basis to Captain, one didn't turn it down.
这是一份艰苦的工作。所以她决定尝试在美国美森航运公司（Matson）晋升，该公司过去曾运营、现在仍在运营从奥克兰到夏威夷的航线。这些年来，我有机会在美森晋升为大副职务。他们对我都很好。当出现临时晋升为船长的机会时，没有人会拒绝。
Yeah, of course not. Why would you? You never knew when that opportunity was going to come along again. Only one hitch. So, despite the fact that I was eight months pregnant. And there's no Dr. On Board of Containership. Let alone no bee or midwife or adula. I said, gosh, you know, I think I got to do this.
是的，当然不会。你为什么会拒绝呢？你永远不知道这样的机会什么时候才会再次降临。只有一个小波折。所以，尽管我当时已经怀孕八个月了。集装箱船上是没有医生的。更不用说没有接生员、助产士或导乐了。我说，天哪，你知道的，我想我得这么做。
And, you know, as you can appreciate, being pregnant is not a handicap. Or, you know, something that should limit your opportunities. It's just something that happens and you kind of carry on with life. So that's what happened. I was eight months pregnant, probably more than eight months pregnant, and said yes, let's go. What was your plan if you'd gone into labor? It was kind of funny because my chief made at the time, um, had recently delivered his own baby in his car. So he was delighted with the idea
而且，你知道的，正如你所理解的那样，怀孕并不是一种残疾。或者，你知道的，某种应该限制你机会的事情。这只是一件发生的事情，你得继续生活。所以事情就是这样。我当时怀孕八个月，可能已经怀孕八个多月了，然后说好的，我们走吧。如果你当时临产了，你的计划是什么？这挺有意思的，因为当时我的大副，嗯，最近刚在车里接生了自己的孩子。所以他很高兴这个想法，
that, oh man, I get to do this and won't that be really fun. Needless to say, it didn't turn into a reality, but what did kind of complicate the situation was after I got off the ship about five days later, I did go into labor and found out that, you know, unbeknownst to me that my son was breached. That means feet first, which makes for substantially more dangerous labor. So should I have gone into labor on the ship, it would have been a much bigger challenge than I think any of us ever anticipated. That two Lynn Corewatch is a down to earth groundbreaking woman in the field of shipping.
天哪，我能做这件事，难道不会真的很有趣吗。不用说，这并没有变成现实，但确实让情况变得有点复杂的是，在我下船大约五天后，我确实临产了，并且发现，你知道的，在我不知情的情况下，我儿子是臀位。这意味着脚先出来，这会让分娩变得更加危险。所以如果我在船上临产，那将是一个比我想象的任何人都预料的要大得多的挑战。林·库尔沃奇也是航运领域一位脚踏实地、具有开创性的女性。
And the long time part of the Bayes Maritime Economy. She's respected by all for her toughness and intelligence. Her track record made her natural fit to become the head of the San Francisco Marine Exchange, which may be the oldest institution in all of California. So the Marine Exchange is an organization that was founded back in 1849 to really track and monitor ships as they arrived in San Francisco Bay. We put the telegraph upon telegraph hill in order to communicate that information down
并且长期以来一直是海湾航运经济的一部分。她的坚韧和智慧赢得了所有人的尊重。她的履历使她自然而然地成为旧金山海事交易所（San Francisco Marine Exchange）的负责人，这可能是全加州最古老的机构。海事交易所是一个成立于1849年的组织，旨在真正追踪和监控抵达旧金山湾的船只。我们在电报山（Telegraph Hill）上架设了电报机，以便将这些信息向下传递
to our maritime partners. We had several relay stations around the Bay. And primarily, we were moving that information around. There was a trading floor so that when we passed this information down to our membership, they were trading commodities right then and there on the floor. They knew that this ship had been coming from South America or from the East Coast or from China because that would be passed through Semaphore or through flags. It's not a stretch to say that San Francisco and all the surrounding towns exist, basically
给我们的海事合作伙伴。我们在海湾周围设立了几个中继站。主要的是，我们在传递这些信息。那里有一个交易大厅，当我们把这些信息传递给我们的会员时，他们就在大厅里即兴交易大宗商品。他们知道这艘船来自南门、东海岸还是中国，因为这些信息会通过信号旗或旗帜传递过来。毫不夸张地说，旧金山和所有周边的城镇之所以存在，基本上
because the Bay had a good port. San Francisco became a part of the global archipelago of important cities. The waterfront area along the Embarcadero was where those break bulk ships came and that's really, you know, where I think the economy of San Francisco grew and grew and grew. Nowadays, the marine exchange knits together the many different pieces of the current maritime economy. They're the honest broker that everyone works with to address stuff like safety and trade, stuff like that. Our mission really hasn't changed. We do exactly the same thing. We don't control ships.
是因为海湾有一个好港口。旧金山成为了重要城市全球群岛的一部分。内河码头（Embarcadero）沿线的滨水区是那些杂货船停靠的地方，那真的，你知道的，我认为旧金山经济不断发展壮大的地方。如今，海事交易所将当前海事经济的许多不同部分编织在一起。他们是每个人都与之合作的诚实经纪人，以处理安全和贸易等问题，诸如此类的事情。我们的使命其实没有改变。我们做着完全相同的事情。我们不控制船舶。
We don't direct ships, we monitor the ships because we do have management part of our organization as well as labor. We have become somewhat of a neutral provider for services. And one of those services is that they publish a book, a book that kind of inspired this entire series that you're listening to, it lists all the businesses that ply the waters. Anchors chains and deckvading, barging, boating services, boilers and water treats.
我们不指挥船舶，我们监控船舶，因为我们的组织中既有管理层也有劳工。我们在一定程度上成为了中立的服务提供商。而他们的服务之一就是出版一本书，一本某种程度上启发了你正在收听的整个系列的图书，它列出了所有在水面上作业的企业。锚链和甲板设备、驳船、划船服务、锅炉和水处理。
Something kind of book you see much anymore. It's spiral bound with lots of tabs. It's a book that's meant to be used. And paging through it, you really see the variety of businesses who ply the waters and supply the ships. The people who bring supplies and service lifeboats and make ropes and haul trash and sell anchors, so many types of businesses that you need to have a functioning maritime economy.
你再也见不到这种书了。它是线圈装订的，有很多标签。这是一本旨在投入使用的书。翻阅它，你真的会看到在水面上作业并为船舶提供补给的各种各样的企业。运送物资、维护救生艇、制造绳索、清运垃圾和销售船锚的人们，要维持一个运转良好的海事经济，你需要如此众多的企业类型。
If the containerships are the big animals, these companies are the little nimble creatures that make the ecosystem work. It's like inside one of these small businesses who works these jobs. I wanted to know, so I called up a tag book company listed in the Marine Exchange Handbook. A few days later, I was sitting across from Ted Blankenberg in a messy office inside a manufactured building right at the foot of the Bay Bridge.
如果集装箱船是大型动物，这些公司就是让生态系统运转的小巧灵敏的生物。就像这些小企业内部是谁在做这些工作一样。我想知道，所以我打电话给海事交易所手册中列出的一家拖船公司。几天后，我坐在贝湾大桥脚下一栋装配式建筑内一间凌乱的办公室里，对面是特德·布兰肯伯格（Ted Blankenberg）。
Let's just say he was an adventurous young man. I went to college, I spent a couple of years in the army, I got on the modern pentathlon team, running, swimming, pistol shooting, fencing, and taking a horse, hopefully over a course. Ted works for MNAV, one of the tugboat companies that services the bay. Like the rest of the maritime economy. Tugboating is inextricably linked with the business of global shipping. He's also a world-class bullshitter and hilarious.
只能说他曾是个爱好冒险的年轻人。我上了大学，在军队待了几年，我加入了现代五项全能队，跑步、游泳、手枪射击、击剑，还有骑马，希望能在赛道上跑完。特德为MNAV工作，这是一家为海湾提供服务的拖船公司。就像海事经济的其余部分一样。拖船业与全球航运业务密不可分。他也是一个世界级的吹牛大王，非常搞笑。
Well, that's a picture of me falling off a horse into a brick wall. He's been around the tugboat industry for 30 years. I was tending bar and a friend of mine's mother owned a tugboat company. And my friend heard my line of a pattern from behind the bar and a friend of mine's mother owned a tugboat company. And my friend heard my line of a pattern from behind the bar and he goes, oh, we got to get you on the air. We need a night dispatcher. So I started working three days a week. This was the best job I ever had.
好吧，那是我的照片，从马背上摔到砖墙上。他在拖船行业已经有30年了。我当时在酒吧兼职，我朋友的母亲拥有是一家拖船公司。我朋友在吧台后面听到我的顺口溜，我朋友的母亲拥有是一家拖船公司。我朋友在吧台后面听到我的顺口溜，然后他说，噢，我们得让你上节目。我们需要一个夜间调度员。所以我开始一周工作三天。这是我做过最好的工作。
Three, 14 hour days a week from four at night till six in the morning and you could sleep a few hours on the job. That was a good gig. But the business of tugboating is changing. Their customers, the big shipping lines, have been locked in fierce competition with each other. And I mean, let's be real. They've been in a race to the bottom. And the shipping companies in the past,
一周三天，每天14个小时，从晚上四点到早上六点，你还可以在工作时睡上几个小时。那真是一份好工作。但拖船业务正在发生变化。他们的客户，各大航运公司，一直在彼此进行激烈的竞争。我的意思是，说实话。他们一直在进行一场没有底线的竞争。过去那些航运公司，
probably since 2008, have been losing their shorts, I mean, by billions of dollars a year. Two consulting firms, Drewry and C Intelligence estimated 2016 shipping industry losses at eight, maybe 10 billion dollars. And each one of those ships is, you know, it costs $150 million, so you have a big old investment, and you're not even making money, you're going to all the stern. Now, how they stay in business, I seriously don't know. How they got to this
大概从2008年开始，就一直在亏本，我是说，每年损失数十亿美元。两家咨询公司德路里（Drewry）和航运情报（C Intelligence）估计，2016年航运业的损失在80亿到100亿美元之间。每一艘船，你知道的，造价1.5亿美元，所以你有一笔很大的老投资，而且你甚至都没在赚钱，你一直在亏损。现在，他们是如何维持经营的，我真的不知道。他们是如何走到这一
point was Merisk, which is the biggest shipping company in the world, or Danish, decided to build ships that were twice as big as all the other ones. Maskline's new triple E class will be the world's largest ships. A record 400 meters long and 59 meters wide. Triple E stands for energy efficiency, environmental performance, and economies of scale. A bunch of shipping lines followed Mayor's lead in building mega mega mega ships. This created a spike in available shipping supply and demand did not follow suit. So as you might expect prices have plummeted. That's meant really really cheap shipping for people importing and exporting stuff. Historically, the Journal of Commerce says that it cost about
步的，是因为全球最大的航运公司、丹麦的马士基（Maersk）决定建造比所有其他船只大两倍的船只。马士基航运的新3E级将是世界最大的船舶。长400米，宽59米，创下纪录。3E代表能源效率（Energy Efficiency）、环保性能（Environmental Performance）和规模经济（Economies of Scale）。许多航运公司效仿马士基的榜样，建造了超级超级超级巨轮。这导致可用航运供应激增，而需求却没有跟上。正如你所料，价格暴跌。对进出口货物的民众来说，这意味着极其便宜的航运。历史上，据《商业日报》报道，在太平洋运送一个集装箱的费用大约是
1800 or 2000 bucks to ship a box across the Pacific. Right now, the price for a big retailer is more like $7 or $800. If you're making brake pads and pantyhose and toothbrushes in China, and you ship in a moment in Nebraska, they're gonna get shipped. Somebody's gonna ship them. And the shipping companies are really your burden.
1800到2000美元。现在，大型零售商的价格更像是700或800美元。如果你在中国制造刹车片、连裤袜和牙刷，然后把它们运到内布拉斯加州，它们就会被运走。总会有人运送它们。而航运公司真的是你的累赘。
And that means they become desperate to somehow survive. They're scared. The number seven in the world went bankrupt. HAN JIN, Korea's once mighty shipper has applied for bankruptcy protection in the United States. Fewer calls means less revenue for all the companies that service ships coming in. The industry is getting tougher and tougher to survive in.
这意味着他们拼命想要设法生存。他们很害怕。世界排名第七的公司破产了。韩国曾经强大的航运公司韩进海运（HAN JIN）已在 美国申请破产保护。船只停靠次数减少意味着为进港船舶提供服务的所有公司的收入减少。这个行业生存变得越来越艰难。
There's no slack left in the system. The local companies have responded with consolidation themselves. Amnav, for example, was purchased by the Marine Resources Group, which became Phos Marine, which is owned by the Seattle Base Salt Chuck Resources Incorporated, a conglomerate that controls 30 logistics businesses. Everybody needs some bigger entity for protection. And that was before Donald Trump started at least talking about a so-called America first trade policy, in which presumably more things are made in the United States and less things are made in Asia.
系统里已经没有任何缓冲余地了。当地公司自己也以整合做出了回应。例如，Amnav被海洋资源集团（Marine Resources Group）收购，后者成为了Phos Marine，而Phos Marine由总部位于西雅图的Salt Chuck Resources Incorporated拥有，这是一个控制着30家物流企业的集团。每个人都需要某种更大的实体来寻求保护。那是唐纳德·特朗普至少开始谈论所谓的“美国优先”贸易政策之前的事，根据该政策，据推测，更多的东西将在美国制造，而在亚洲制造的东西会更少。
If you've already got too much shipping capacity out on the ocean, and then the US suddenly starts importing fewer things. That could send an already stressed industry into a plosive decline. And the blast radius could extend far beyond the West Coast ports. 12% of US GDP, roughly $2 trillion worth of the economy, is dependent on goods flowing through the West Coast. You mess with that, and you're literally gambling with the national economy. And yet, the little maritime business is soldier on, doing the work,
如果你在公海上已经有了太多的航运产能，然后美国突然开始减少进口商品。那可能会让一个本已压力重重的行业陷入崩溃性的衰退。而爆炸半径可能会远远超出西海岸港口。美国GDP的12%，大约2万亿美元的经济价值，都依赖于通过西海岸流动的货物。你把这搞砸了，你就是在拿国民经济开玩笑。然而，小型海事企业仍在坚持，继续工作，
despite the corporate squeeze and the darkness on the horizon, just like all the rest of the companies and unions who make the supply chain go. Every time a ship comes in it's like putting on a wedding. I mean you've got a myriad of details and you forget one and it's just awful. You got to notify the Coast Guard and order up longshore ganks to unload ships and line handlers to tie the big boat up. You need tugboats and a bar pilot to pilot the cargo ship into the bay directing the movements of the tugs. The ship shows up 12 miles west of the Golden Gate Bridge. A pilot will board and take it into the bay all the way to which birth.
尽管面临企业的挤压和地平线上的阴霾，就像供应链中所有其他公司和工会一样。每当一艘船进港，就像办一场婚礼。我是说，你有无数的细节，你忘了一个，那就太糟糕了。你得通知海岸警卫队，预定码头工人卸船，并安排系缆工把大船绑好。你需要拖船和引航员来引导货船进入海湾，指挥拖船的运动。货船出现在金门大桥以西12英里处。引航员将登船并将其带入海湾，一直带到指定的泊位。
After I learned about the business, I wanted to see what the actual work was. Like how does this work get accomplished? What does a tugboat do? So I asked Ted and he got me on a boat called the Patricia Anne. Will is the skipper of the Patricia Anne. Our job for the afternoon is to guide a medium-sized container ship called the Cat Palaceer off the dock and out of the Oakland Shipping Channel. It's tied up at birth 59 of the Oakland Container Terminal, and it's a pretty standard two tugboat
在我了解了这项业务之后，我想看看实际的工作是什么样的。比如这项工作是如何完成的？拖船是做什么的？所以我问了特德，他把我安排在了一艘名叫“帕特里夏·安”号（Patricia Anne）的船上。威尔是“帕特里夏·安”号的船长。我们下午的任务是引导一艘名为“卡特·帕利塞尔”号（Cat Palisser）的中型集装箱船离开码头，驶出奥克兰航道。它停靠在奥克兰集装箱码头的59号泊位，这是一个相当标准的双拖船
job. We'll be pulling it off the dock, taking it up to the turning basin, turning basin, spinning it around, and probably getting released somewhere along the inner harbor. So this orange vessel ship up here, ports I too, that's the cap halister. Though it's not a large ship by the standards of the industry, it is enormous by any other standard.
作业。我们将把它从码头拉开，把它带到转头水域，转头水域，让它掉头，然后可能在内港的某个地方解除任务。所以前面那个橙色的船只，港口我也有，那就是“卡特·帕利塞尔”号。虽然按照行业的标准它不是一艘大船，但按照任何其他标准来看它都是巨大的。
We cruise past the cat palisers and will snuggles the tug up against the dock to await orders. Waiting for the call, we look out at the big Oakland International Container Terminal, one of the busiest terminals on the west coast. There's stacks of boxes bearing the names of the big shipping lines, Merck, MSC, CMA, CGM, APL, Costco. It used to be the individual lines, operated ships, and their own terminals. Now, what are called stevedoring companies run these places,
我们从“卡特·帕利塞尔”号旁边驶过，威尔将拖船紧靠着码头停好以等待命令。等待呼叫时，我们眺望巨大的奥克兰国际集装箱终端，这是西海岸最繁忙的终端之一。那里堆叠着印有各大航运公司名称的集装箱：马士基（Maersk）、地中海航运（MSC）、达飞轮船（CMA CGM）、美国总统轮船（APL）、中远海运（Cosco）。过去，各家航运公司运营着自己的船只和码头。现在，所谓的装卸公司在管理这些地方，
leasing the land from the port of Oakland and servicing a bunch of different ship lines. This particular one is run by SSA, stevedoring Services of America. The guys unloading the ships are all members of ILWU, the Longshore Union. What we're looking out at is a huge and highly diverse slice of the working class.
他们从奥克兰港租用土地，并为许多不同的航运公司提供服务。这个特定的码头由SSA（美国装卸服务公司，Stevedoring Services of America）运营。卸货的工人们都是ILWU（国际码头和仓库工会）的成员。我们眼前看到的是极其庞大且多样化的工人阶层。
Call the dogs, so they can't out for a 50-trile. Be sure I'll be real quick, have a new one. And, got the end, good afternoon. Have a new guys, have a new year. So, some stuff. Down, some stuff now. Seven, seven. Try to make a very nice light out.
呼叫狗狗，这样他们就无法应对50英里……确信我会非常快，有一个新的。然后，结束了，下午好。有新的人，新年快乐。所以，一些东西。倒下，现在一些东西。七，七。试着做一盏非常漂亮的灯。
And, Patty, so we'll do the turn. We'll have you pushing on the port bow once we make our... The first step is to hit ourselves to the ship. We have a line on our tug that attaches to a line on the ship, and whether the tug is pushing or pulling the container ship, the tug stays attached on these ropes. These lines are very, very strong. I mean, they're partially woven out of Kevlar. Once this line gets up, we'll receive a signal, and then what I'll do is I'll come back and
然后，帕蒂，我们来转弯。一旦我们做好了……第一步是把自己系到船上。我们的拖船上有一根系缆绳，连接到船上的一根缆绳上，无论拖船是在推还是在拉集装箱船，拖船都通过这些绳索保持连接。这些缆绳非常非常结实。我的意思是，它们部分是由凯夫拉纤维编织而成的。这根缆绳升起后，我们会收到一个信号，然后我要做的是返回
push on the side of the ship so that they can take in their lines and the ship will still be pressed up. We're pressed up against the container ship when the longshoreman released the lines on shore. Our tugs are there to keep the ship from bobbing around until we're ready to pull it off the dock. You often see tugboats in this position pressed up at a 90 degree angle to the ships they're about to work. Now it's time to start pulling the cap halus or off the dock. It happens almost imperceptibly. The ship is so huge and it moves so slowly and smoothly. And the tug crew is so calm that I was not actually sure what was going on. Now that we've got the ship off the dock, we power
推船的侧面，这样他们就可以收起缆绳，船仍然会被压紧。当码头工人在岸上松开缆绳时，我们紧紧贴着集装箱船。我们的拖船在那里阻止船只上下晃动，直到我们准备好把它拉离码头。你经常看到拖船处于这种位置，以90度的角度紧贴着它们准备作业的船只。现在是时候开始把“卡特·帕利塞尔”号拉离码头了。这个过程几乎令人察觉不到。船太巨大了，它的移动如此缓慢和平稳。拖船船员又是如此镇定，以至于我其实并不确定发生了什么。既然我们已经把船拉离了码头，我们就开往
down to what's called the turning basin. It's a wide area of the shipping channel where we'll spin the container ship so it's turned around to exit the bay into the Pacific Ocean. We'll be pushing from one side and another tugboat will be pushing from the other side of this massive ship, causing it to spin like a revolving door. It's an incredible moment being right up against this thing. I expected to crunch more or something to really feel like we were muscling it, but it doesn't. There's no sound of metal straining. The tugboat hardly seems to move. The water simply parts, and the wall of metal looming above us rotates.
所谓的转头水域。这是航道中的一个宽阔区域，我们将在那里让集装箱船旋转，使其掉头驶出海湾进入太平洋。我们将从一侧推，另一艘拖船将从这艘巨大巨轮的另一侧推，使其像旋转门一样旋转。紧靠着这个庞然大物是一种不可思议的体验。我以为会听到更多的嘎吱声，或者真正感觉到我们在强行推动它，但并没有。没有听到金属紧绷的声音。拖船似乎几乎没有移动。水流自然分开，我们头顶上方高耸的金属墙旋转起来。
The last task will be to ride alongside the ship as we head out. The tug's act is brakes, so the big ship doesn't get going too fast. We're going alongside right now, so mostly ships, they're like, if you put it in terms of a car, their first gear is like eight knots or nine knots. Though that's only nine or ten miles per hour, that kind of speed in a narrow shipping channel can rock the other ships alongside the dock, damaging them, so the tugs drag backwards on their lines. Stop and drive, patty.
最后的任务是在我们驶出时陪伴在船侧。拖船充当刹车，这样大船就不会开得太快。我们现在正并排航行，所以大多数船只，如果用汽车来形容，它们的一档就像8节或9节。虽然这只有每小时9到10英里，但在狭窄的航道中这种速度会使码头旁边的其他船只摇晃，从而损坏它们，因此拖船在缆绳上向后拉。停下并开动，帕蒂。
We're finally given our release to go home. It's time to take our line in. Get your patty ready to get taken in up. Yep, we're getting under it right now. All in the move takes a couple of hours, though most of the action takes place in just a few moments. Soon, we're back at the dock. The trucks have begun streaming in
我们终于获准回家了。是时候收回缆绳了。准备好收回帕蒂。是的，我们现在正在收。整个移动过程需要几个小时，尽管大部分动作只发生在短短的几个瞬间。很快，我们回到了码头。卡车已经开始涌入
to pick up containers from another big ship that had come to shore. While bigger ships mean less business for the tugboats, it also puts pressure on the truckers. As a whole, they need to pick up more boxes, and they still only have the same amount of time, about four days, to clear the containers out of the terminal. That creates a bigger, trucker-demand spike causing congestion around the port. In other words, fewer bigger ships mix the water too empty and the land
去从另一艘靠岸的大船上取走集装箱。虽然更大的船意味着拖船的业务减少，但也给卡车司机带来了压力。总体而言，他们需要装载更多的集装箱，而他们仍然只有相同的时间，大约四天，来清空码头上的集装箱。这造成了更大的卡车司机需求高峰，导致港口周围拥堵。换句话说，更少的大型船只使水面过于空旷，而陆地
too crowded. At least here in Oakland, some places have done very well in the mega-ship era. In general, the trend among ports has been increasing centralization. So imagine a map of the world, with lines connecting different ports, and the thickness of the line represents how much stuff gets shipped along that route. In the pre-container days, there would be lots of skinny lines going all over the place. As containerization took hold in the 1970s, and later China entered the WTO in the 90s, the lines connecting China to a few ports on the west coast get really fat, swallowing up other trade routes.
过于拥挤。至少在奥克兰这里，一些地方在巨轮时代做得非常成功。总体而言，港口的趋势一直是日益中心化。所以想象一下世界地图，用线条连接不同的港口，线条的粗细代表了沿这条路线运送货物的多少。在集装箱出现之前的日子里，会有很多细小的线条通往各处。随着20世纪70年代集装箱化的普及，以及后来中国在90年代加入世贸组织，连接中国和西海岸少数几个港口的线条变得非常粗，吞噬了其他贸易路线。
The way it played out in the US is at the San Pedro Bay, which is where the competing but connected ports of Long Beach and Los Angeles are located begin to dominate everyone. In 2015, for example, these two ports handled 78% of the import containers along the West Coast. And for all the West Coast ports, 62% of imports came from China, damn near 50% of all the import trade from Asia to the West Coast is just running back and forth from San Pedro Bay to China. I ended up talking all this over, in a conversation with Tim Wong, a Berkeley-educated lawyer and local polymath who published the Container Guida, wonderful little book on the shipping industry disguised as a dockside companion to spotting boxes.
它在美国的表现是，圣佩德罗湾（San Pedro Bay，长滩和洛杉矶这两个相互竞争但又相互联系的港口所在地）开始主导所有人。例如，在2015年，这两个港口处理了西海岸78%的进口集装箱。在所有西海岸港口中，62%的进口来自中国，从亚洲到西海岸的所有进口贸易中，差不多有50%只是在圣佩德罗湾和中国之间来回奔波。我最终在与蒂姆·王（Tim Wong）的对话中讨论了这一切，他是一名伯克利毕业的律师兼当地的博学者，他出版了《集装箱指南》（Container Guida），一本关于航运业的精彩小书，伪装成识别集装箱的码头伴侣。
In ports, as in ships, he said, everything has become a size and efficiency. Can you get big enough to stay alive and keep your whole maritime business ecosystem healthy? Oakland was able to survive for a period of time, but as technology gets better, the cost of choosing one port or another on the Western seaboard, they all become a commodity. This is the same trouble that's happened with the container companies themselves, the liner companies, where they're basically selling this commodity, which always is dropping, the value of it is always dropping. There's lots of incentives to overproduce capacity in ways that completely drive everybody
他说，在港口，正如在船上一样，一切都变成了规模和效率。你能做到足够大以维持生存并保持整个海事商业生态系统的健康吗？奥克兰得以生存了一段时间，但随着技术的进步，在西海岸选择这个港口还是那个港口的成本，它们都变成了商品。这与集装箱公司（班轮公司）本身发生的情况相同，他们基本上在销售这种商品，而这种商品的价值总是在下降，价值总是在下降。有很大的动机以完全把所有人挤出局的方式过度生产产能，或者使得只有能够从巨额交易中榨取微小利润的最大公司才能真正生存下来。我想有一段时间，地理位置基本上是这些港口的最大保护，对吧？因为它们可以吞并所有较小的区域性港口，而不必与更大的港口竞争。但随着船只在移动方式上变得更加高效，它们突然基本上与其他港口站在同一起跑线上竞争。而
out of business or make it so that only the largest companies that can squeeze tiny pennies out of huge numbers of transactions actually can survive. And I wonder for a period of time, basically geography was the great protection of these ports, right? Because they could eat up all the smaller, regional ones, but not have to compete with much larger ones. But as boats get more efficient in the way they move, suddenly they basically compete on the same footing with other ports. And
在那里，地理位置就不再能帮到你了，对吧？真正开始帮到你的是，你能否真正扩大港口的规模，而奥克兰可能无法在那里足够快地扩张？在世界各地，越来越多的业务集中在越来越少的港口。然而，它们需要维持拖船等所有服务的整个生态系统。对于奥克兰来说，进口业务在这一点上永远不会变得大得多。
there, then the geography server doesn't help you anymore, right? What really starts to help you is, can you really scale up the size of the port and maybe Oakland just can't expand fast enough there? Across the world, more and more business is centralizing in fewer and fewer ports. And yet they need to maintain the whole ecosystem of services like tugboats and all that stuff. The import game is never going to be that much bigger for Oakland at this point.
但它们或许能够扩大出口规模。这是因为地理位置对它们来说依然重要。把它想象成货物的流域，如果你愿意的话，是一个货棚。奥克兰自然而然地辐射了整个中央山谷（Central Valley），更不用说纳帕（Napa）和索诺马（Sonoma）了，它们是该国最重要的几个农业区。因此，港口官员希望利用这一优势进行扩张。
But they might be able to scale up their exports. That's because geography remains important for them. Think of it almost like a watershed for cargo, a cargo shed, if you will. Oakland naturally drains the whole Central Valley, not to mention Napa and Sonoma, which are some of the most important agricultural regions in the country. So the port officials want to expand on that strength,
但他们或许能够扩大出口规模。这是因为地理位置对他们来说依然重要。你可以把它想象成货物的集水区，或者说货棚。奥克兰自然连接着整个中央山谷，更不用说纳帕和索诺玛了，它们是该国最重要的几个农业区。因此，港口官员希望在此优势的基础上进一步扩展,
building a huge refrigerated facility that would allow Midwestern meat producers to put their port on a train, and send it all the way to the ocean to the port. From there, it had shipped out to China. You end up with this capitalist virtuous circle, the efficiency of global shipping allowed for the production of electronics and all kinds of other stuff in China,
建造一个庞大的冷藏设施，可以让中西部地区的肉类生产商将猪肉装上火车，一直运送到海港。从那里运往中国。最终形成了资本主义的良性循环，全球航运的效率使得中国能够生产电子产品和各种其他物品，
which helped create their middle class. And now that burgeoning group of wealthier Chinese people end up importing American goods, driving our own economy. But that only works if American producers can send those goods to China. If we end up in a trade war, those pork and wine exports are in trouble. Containers is produced and hosted by Alexis Madrigal
这反过来帮助他们建立起了中产阶级。现在，这群不断壮大的、更富裕的中国人群最终开始进口美国商品，从而推动了我们自己的经济。但这只有在美国生产商能够将这些商品运往中国的前提下才行得通。如果我们陷入贸易战，那些猪肉和葡萄酒出口就会陷入困境。《集装箱》由亚历克西斯·马德里加尔制作并主持，
with editing production and sound design by Jonathan Hirsch. You can find the eight-part series, I think they're on episode five right now, on iTunes or wherever you get podcasts. 99% Invisible is Avery Trouffman, Katie Mingle, Kurt Colstead, Taren Mazza, Delaney Hall, Sharif Yusif, Emmith Fitzgerald, Sean Riel, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 K-A-L-W in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row.
编辑、制作和声音设计由乔纳森·赫什完成。你可以通过iTunes或任何你收听播客的地方找到这部八集系列节目，我想他们现在正播到第五集。《99%隐形》的成员包括埃弗里·特鲁夫曼、凯蒂·明格、库尔特·科尔斯特ッド、塔伦·马扎、德莱尼·霍尔、谢里夫·尤西夫、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、肖恩·里尔以及我——罗曼·马尔斯。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW电台的一个项目，在广播街区制作。
In beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. You can find this show and like the show on Facebook. All of us are on Twitter, Instagram, and Spotify, but to find out more about this story, including cool pictures and links, and listen to all the episodes of 99% Invisible. You must go to 99pi.org. Radio Tapio.
位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的市中心。你可以在Facebook上找到并喜欢这个节目。我们所有人都在Twitter、Instagram和Spotify上，但要了解关于这个故事的更多信息，包括精美的图片和链接，并收听《99%隐形》的所有节目，你必须访问99pi.org。Radio Tapio。
From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
来自PRX。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。